in 2018 Americans voted for who would
represent them in Congress but in North
Carolina the election results were
really weird these squares represent all
the voters in North Carolina they were
voting for these 13 seats in Congress
about half voted for Republicans and
about 48% voted for Democrats so you
might think of the 13 congressional
seats maybe Democrats would have won six
seats and Republicans would have won
seven but now Democrats only 1/3 of 13
seats way less than half this imbalance
was because North Carolina's
congressional districts had been
gerrymandered it means that these voters
had been grouped into districts very
strategically with the goal of
benefiting one party gerrymandering has
pretty much always happened in America
that's because every ten years the
political districts are redrawn and in
most cases those new lines get drawn by
whoever holds power in state government
at the time that's what happened in 2010
Republicans won control of lots of state
governments and redrew the political
lines to favor themselves in over the
next few years
redistricting help them hold on to
almost all those states this shifted the
balance of power and it turns out behind
a lot of this was one guy usually the
voters get to pick the politicians
in redistricting the politicians get to
pick the voters
this is Thomas hofler the mapmaker who
helped Republicans gerrymander districts
over the last decade when hofler died in
2018 his daughter found thousands of his
emails and files which she shared with
activists the files show that Tom
Hoffler fingerprints are all over the
way America's political maps look today
but North Carolina was his masterpiece
and if you want to understand why
gerrymandering is such a big problem in
the US that's a good place to start the
basics of gerrymandering are actually
pretty simple
if you're a Republican trying to keep
power you want to do two things first
pack as many Democratic voters as
possible into a single district if you
have a district where almost everyone
votes Democrat that means almost half
these votes are basically wasted you can
also crack big democratic areas into
separate districts where there are
slightly more Republicans so even though
an area has a lot of Democratic votes
they would actually lose in this
district and in this district these are
the two elements of classic
gerrymandering pecking and cracking and
hofler employed these techniques
masterfully in North Carolina in 2011 he
was hired to redraw the state's
political lines and four congressional
districts he came up with this map now I
just want to focus in on district 12
this weird skinny shape in order to make
sense of this shape we have to look at
another map this map shows the
percentage of black people in each
neighborhood
the bluer areas are where more black
people live huh Fleur basically gathered
up black people in winston-salem
Greensboro and Charlotte and packed them
into one district
so that's how district 12 happened huh
Fleur also do this with North Carolina
state representatives and state senators
for example here the state Senate
districts here he packed winston-salem
into one district and then packed
Greensboro into its own district these
new districts help Republicans get a
stranglehold on power in the North
Carolina Statehouse and over the next
few years they were able to pass crucial
legislation a strict new voter ID law in
North Carolina which bathrooms
transgender individuals can use in North
Carolina in 2016 and 2017 federal courts
ruled that both of these maps were
unconstitutional they said what North
Carolina Republicans did wasn't just
gerrymandering it was a racial
gerrymandering done to deliberately
dilute the political power of black
people the court said the Republicans in
the North Carolina State House now had
to redraw the lines without looking at
racial demographics so they went back to
Tom Hoffler this time Hoffler couldn't
look at race instead he looked at which
areas voted for Democrats in which areas
voted for Republicans instead of a
racial gerrymander it would be a
partisan gerrymander here's that map
using data from 2014 the blue or an area
the more democratic voters there are now
if you zoom in here to Greensboro you
can see one of the highest
concentrations of Democratic voters in
the state Hoffler drew a congressional
district line to crack this community in
half this meant Democrats here for now
in the minority and their district and
Democrats here were also in the minority
in their district Hoffler employed these
techniques all over the state to create
North Carolina's new political districts
and the first big test for these new
maps would be the 2018 election
Democrats were expected to turn out in
droves Democrats are vying for a
potential blue wave the wave that
Republicans fear is going to wipe them
up so how do the maps do
for state representatives Democrats got
51 percent of the vote they only won 46
percent of seats
for state Senate they received half the
vote and won just 42 percent of seats
and for Congress you already know how
that one turned out democrats won nearly
half the votes but won only 3 out of 13
seats
a year later in 2019 the Supreme Court
weighed in they said it was beyond their
reach that it wasn't their job to fix it
all of this raised an existential
question if Republicans could continue
drawing the lines to stay in power how
could they ever be elected out of office
but the Supreme Court's ruling left open
the possibility for state courts to rule
on partisan gerrymandering and in
September 2019 that's exactly what North
Carolina Supreme Court did the court
found that partisan gerrymandering
violated the state constitution in the
court's decision it was ha fleurs files
that help prove that North Carolina
Republicans drew these lines with a
clear intention of benefitting
themselves ultimately the court said
North Carolina Republicans had a redraw
the Statehouse in state Senate maps one
more time this new map approved by North
Carolina legislators is much less biased
toward one party even though it took
some extreme measures and nearly a
decade to force politicians to draw a
fair map in the last few years the
courts in several states like Florida
and Pennsylvania have made partisan
gerrymandering much harder and now
that's also the case in North Carolina
huh Fleur is gone now but in other
states across the country many maps he
helped draw are still in use and while
there's now a clear strategy to
challenge those maps in state courts
many voters are still effectively not
choosing their representatives
it's like Hoffler said the
representatives are choosing the voters
of course redistricting is democracy at
work redistricting is like an election
in Reverse it's a great event
[Music]